TO GET THIS IS AN IMPORTANT SHOW
.
S&L GETS FLACK FOR BOASTING THA
DAVE CHAPELLE WILL BE HOSTING.
SATURDAY NIGHT LIFE IS BEING
SLAMMED FORWARD TRANS PHOBIA
AFTER ANNOUNCING DAVE CHAPELLE
WILL HOST THE SHOW, SHOCKING
REGULAR VIEWERS WHO AREN'T USED
TO BEING SOMEONE BEING FUNNY.
S&L THOUGHT HE WOULD BE GOOD TO
US BECAUSE HE IS ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST POPULAR COMEDIANS
, BUT THEY FORGOT ABOUT
THE 14 ONLINE WHINERS WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO CONTROL EVERYTHING
WE WATCH OUR DEAR, ONE OF THEM
WAS THE FORMER CO- VICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSGENDER ENFORC
NEW MATERIAL FIELD WHO TWEETED,
WEIGHT, I THOUGHT I CANCELED HIM
, IS IT POSSIBLE CANCEL
CULTURE ISN'T A RARE THING?
FAIRPOINT, BUT IF YOU PROTEST
THE STREAMING HAS SPECIAL.
SO SHE DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
CANCELING HERSELF RIGHT
HOPEFULLY S&L STAYS STRONG.
THE BACKLASH FROM THE ONLINE MO
CAN FEEL BIGGER THAN IT IS
ESPECIALLY NEW FORGET THAT IT'S
JUST ONE PERSON WHO GOES BY THEM
.
THEY SHOULD LET S&L FOCUS ON
BRING BACK THE CLASSICS GETS
THAT MADE US LAUGH, ESPECIALLY
THE CONEHEADS.
IS THIS ESSENCE, THAT MAY BE
THINGS ARE CHANGING.
LIKE S&L WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THA
A YEAR AGO, BUT NOW THEY ARE.
>> THINGS HAVEN'T REALLY CHANGED
, IT SAYS THAT PEOPLE ARE
REALIZING THE WAY THAT THINGS
ARE GREAT I WROTE A MEGAN IS TH
PIECE WHEN STICKS AND STONES
SPECIAL CAME OUT, BECAUSE ON
ROTTEN TOMATOES THERE WAS A 30
PERCENT CRITICS RATINGS BUT
THE AUDIENCE RATING WAS 99
PERCENT.
PEOPLE AREN'T ACTUALLY THAT
OFFENDED, THAT MANY PEOPLE
AREN'T THAT OFFENDED, ITS PEOPL
PRETENDING THEY ARE BECAUSE THE
DON'T WANT TO GET CANCELED,
PRODUCERS OF SHOWS AND STUFF
LIKE THAT, THEY ARE REALIZING
THESE PEOPLE, THERE AREN'T THAT
MANY OF THEM.
GET THE THING IS, THEY ARE
REALLY LOUD.
THEY TRULY ARE AT THEY BECAUSE
ONE PERSON COULD BE IF YOU DON'
HAVE A JOB, YOU CAN BE 500
PEOPLE ONLINE.
RIGHT?
>> OR IF YOU ARE JUST YOU LOOK
LIKE 500 PEOPLE.
I AM OFFENDED, HOW DARE YOU.
>> SORRY, DID THAT SLIP OUT?
SHEEP MEANT THAT I THOUGHT
ORIGINALLY TONGUE-IN-CHEEK, BUT
I THOUGHT SHE WAS SERIOUS.
>> SHE IS THE ONE THAT LED THE
EMPLOYEE RESOURCE GROUP AND
RETIRED OVER THE SPECIAL.
THE WHOLE THING IS NOBODY.
QUITS, BECAUSE THERE ARE 20
PEOPLE IN LINE FOR YOUR JOB.
ZERO-TOLERANCE FOR THAT.
>> IS THAT THAT WAS SUCH EASE,
DON'T THINK THAT WAS YOUR FIRST
TIME.
GO AHEAD AND QUIT, [BLEEP], I
THINK YOU HAVE SAID THAT TO A
NUMBER OF NFL PROFESSIONAL
CHEERLEADERS.
>> I'VE HEARD IT ON THE RADIO
SHOW AT LEAST FIVE TIMES.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS A
SOME POINT DURING THE WHATEVER,
WHAT DO THEY DO, THE REHEARSALS?
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE
BREAKDOWNS?
>> KNOW THEY'RE NOT.
TWO THINGS FED FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WHEN IT COMES TO
COMEDY, I COULDN'T RESIST BEARS.
>> I ENJOYED THAT.
YOU ARE GETTING TREATED AS AN
EQUAL.
YOU NOT GETTING PUT UP IN THE
CORNER AS SOME SORT OF INFANTIL
LESSER THEN.
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENED TO THI
BLOWBACK AND THE REASON IT SO
USES AS EVERYBODY FIGURED OUT
WHAT CANCEL CULTURE WAS, AND KA
MADE THIS POINT.
I USED TO DRIVE A TAXI.
THERE WAS A STREET HUSTLE, HE
MIGHT HAVE HEARD OF CALLED THE
LEMON DROP.
WITH THE LEMON DROP IS IS A GUY
WALKED UP TO YOU BUMP INTO YOU
COME AND DROP HIS GLASSES ON TH
GROUND AND BE LIKE YOU BROKE MY
GLASSES, YOU BROKE MY GLASSES
AND YOU WANT HIM TO GO AWAY SEE
GIVE HER MONEY.
CANCEL CULTURE WAS THE LEMON
DROP.
NOW THAT WE REALIZE IT'S A SCAM
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
>> IT IS LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD ANALOGY.
>> THANK YOU.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH HIM
BEING A CABDRIVER.
>> I USED TO SEE AT.
>> I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF THI
STREET GAME.
AND YOU COULD'VE SAID.
YOU COULD JUST UPSET A LOT OF
THINGS.
>> WHEN I THINK OF THIS STREETS
I THINK GREG GUTFELD.
>> I GREW UP ON THE STREET
SPIRIT.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO BE TEAM TURF ON THIS ON
AND I'M GOING TO ROLL WITH
CHAPELLE.
AT THINK IT'S FUNNY WHEN SOMEON
SAYS I THOUGHT I CANCELED HIM
AND NO ONE KNOWS WHO YOU ARE, I
S&L HAS THE BALLS TO STICK WITH
IT, I AM FORWARD TO HIS OPENING
STATEMENT.
WHY EVEN WASTE YOUR TIME IN
DEALING WITH THAT, YOU CAN SIT
IN ANYONE THAT THESE CHAIRS ANY
TIME, YOU CAN EVEN GUEST HOST
HERE, WE'D LIKE TO LAUGH AND
RELATE COMEDY AND THE FACT THAT
WE WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT THE
STORY IF YOU DIDN'T MAKE US REA
IT.
I WOULD NOT HAVE KNOWN NOTHING
ABOUT I THOUGHT I CANCELED
TEMPERATE REALLY, YOUTH DID?
NO ONE ELSE THAT YOU DID.
WHO'S EVER RESIGNED FROM A JOB
IN BED LIKE YEAH, I ONE.
>> MEET WHEN I CLICKED FROM
BOSTON MARKET RIGHT BEFORE
THANKSGIVING.
>> I GOT A JOB IS A WAITRESS
THAT WILL MAKE WAY MORE MONEY.
>> I WAS NOT IN A POSITION AND
MY LIFE TO LOOK OUT FOR ANYONE,
BUT ME.
GIVE MEANING, WHAT WAS YOUR
PHRASE?
>> L, I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> YOU PUT IT UP THERE.
YOU WENT FROM SERVIN